Herzlich willkommen zur Alternativlos, die Folge 3.
Diesmal aus Akustikgründen haben wir uns einen besonders schönen kirchlich klingenden Raum gesucht. Wir haben uns gedacht, wenn wir ihr die Wahrheit erzählen, dann können wir auch mal in die Kirche gehen.
Wir sind tatsächlich in einem Quake-Level, das sich UDK nennt, UDK ist es nicht, UDK. Eigentlich wollten wir in ein Café gehen, aber die Hintergrundbauer schafften so momentane audio-technik zu krass. Deswegen sind wir über die Straße gegangen und ein wenig durch dieses schöne Quake-Level hier geirrt und haben dann ein schönes Foyer mit Treppe und Steckdose gefunden, wo wir uns jetzt befinden.
Und es klingt wie ein U-Boot. Also wenn hier einer hinten lang läuft und es knarrt und knarrtst und so, dann haltest du hier durch das Gebäude und es klingt wie so das Boot.
Ach na ja, ich glaube, die U-Boot-Fahrer wären froh gewesen, wenn sie so ein schön klingendes Boot gehabt hätten, oder? Aber gut, man hört so schöne Hintergrundgeräusche hinten. Da muss man sich dann mit abfinden.
Die Akustik ist schön hier. Ja, also wir haben uns diesmal wieder, fangen wir mit Bauhausmeister-Themen an.
Ja, das erste ist, am 11. September findet in Berlin wieder die Freiheit statt Angst-Demo statt. Nun schon zum dritten Mal? Viertem Mal?
Also vierten Mal.
Viertem Mal, dritten Mal. Also jedenfalls wird es langsam zur tradition und ihr seid natürlich alle herzlich eingeladen zu kommen. Und mitzudemonstrieren gegenüber Wachungswahn und was sich sonst noch so auf dem Herzen liegt.
Es gibt da auch gerade eine frische Chaos-Ride-Sendung zum Thema.
Genau, von gestern. Die müsste mittlerweile sogar schon online sein. Und ansonsten haben wir noch den Kongress-Call for Proposals, der ist vor participation, der ist jetzt auch raus, schon seit einer Weile, genau wie gesagt seit Ende Juli. Zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr ist wie immer der chaos-communication-kongress, wo ihr eingeladen seid, wenn ihr interessante Dinge vorzutragen habt, vorbeizukommen und den Vortrag dazu einzureichen. Die URL dazu findet sich glaube ich auch auf www.wccc.de, ne?
Ja, und die werden wir auch in die Linksammlung aufnehmen.
Stimmt, ja.
Ja, ansonsten haben wir gesagt, fangen wir an mit der Contentmafia und der Netzneutralität, weil das gerade so ein Thema ist, was im Netz die Leute mitnimmt. Wie kam das jetzt eigentlich hoch gerade? Das waren nicht die Thesen von Demisier, sondern es gab gerade noch ein...
Na, die Netzneutralität kam hoch, weil Google einen Deal mit amerikanischem ISP gemacht hat und was von vielen Leuten als Verrat empfunden wurde, gesagt hat, naja, mit der Netzneutralität, hm, da können wir vielleicht ja nochmal drüber reden. Wir könnten uns noch mal darauf einigen, dass die Netzneutralität zwar für fixed networks gilt, also Kabel und DSL, aber bei den mobilen Netzwerken, da würden wir doch gerne dafür sorgen, dass der Google-Content gegen einen kleinen Obolus an den Mobilfunkanbieter bevorzugt befördert wird. Und das wäre natürlich ein Bruch mit dem, ja, sozusagen dem Dogma der Netzneutralität, was halt da lautet, dass keine Inhalte bevorzugt befördert werden sollen.
Also interessanterweise war dieser Vertrag zwischen Google und Verizon gar nicht so, wie der erste Eindruck war, sondern da stand im Grunde drin. Verizon, sollen wir bitte weiterhin ein bisschen auf Netzneutralität achten. Das heißt, Google war nicht so, ist nicht so daneben, wie das in der Presse erstmal berichtet wurde. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem doof, weil es ein Fluttor eröffnet, was wir eigentlich lieber geschlossen gehalten hätten.
Also um es da eigentlich im Kern geht, ist die Furcht, dass wenn man erstmal anfängt, Inhalte im Netz zu differenzieren, also die Transportgeschwindigkeit von Inhalten, nicht aus technischen Gründen, sondern aus inhaltlichen Gründen zu differenzieren, dass dann der Weg auch nicht mehr fern ist, wenn zum Beispiel solche Podcasts wie dieser hier, dann eben es sich nicht leisten können, dafür zu bezahlen, dass sie bevorzugt transportiert werden, dass sie dann halt nur sehr langsam im Netz runterzuladen sind oder halt gegenüber anderen Diensten mehr nachteiligt werden.
Genau, also das fehlt uns auch so ein bisschen in der Debatte gerade, dass keiner eigentlich definiert, was eigentlich Netzneutralität ist. Es gibt da auch ein, was nicht, es war kein Gesetzentwurf, aber es war so was Ähnliches. Ein Vorstoß von irgendeiner offiziellen Seite in Deutschland. Und da war, genau eine petition war das richtig, es war eine petition gerade, die gab es. Und da stand aber auch nicht drin, was eigentlich Netzneutralität sein soll.
Es gibt zwei Sachen. Es gibt zum einen diese komische Erklärung, die halt so aus dieser SPD-grünen Parteien kam.
Genau, die wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht erwähnen, aber gut.
Gut, die verlegen wir gerade nicht. Aber es gibt halt eher noch eine richtige petition im Bundestag, die halt ein bisschen schwammig formuliert ist, aber die immerhin mal den klar sagt, dass es darum geht, dass Inhalte gleichberechtigt transportiert werden sollen und nicht mit diesem ganzen Wirtschaftsfuhr anfängt, der da immer als hilfsargumentation angezogen wird, wo heute einige Leute der Meinung sind, dass der jetzt irgendwie den Tag retten würde.
Es ist auch noch relativ wichtig, dass man da nicht von Empfängersaiter argumentiert. Also das passiert häufig in der diskussion, dass die Leute sagen, ich möchte nicht, dass dieser Inhalt schneller bei mir ankommt. Darum geht es nicht, sondern es geht darum, dass alle Sender gleichberechtigt sind. Das ist der Kern der Netzneutralität.
Also das Recht, in jedem Protokoll unbeliebige Verschlüsselung zu senden und dabei gleichberechtigt transportiert zu werden, das ist eigentlich der Kern der Netzneutralität aus unserer Sicht. Und in Frankreich gibt es ja schon dieses Freestrikes.
Moment, wir wollten erst noch auf die Contentmafia eingehen.
Das war nämlich der humoristische Aspekt.
Dass die Contentmafia gekommen ist und meinte, sie könnte jetzt die Netzneutralitätsdebatte kapern, um ihre Idee der Netzneutralität unterzubringen, die nämlich heißt, naja, aber Robbkopierte Inhalte, die sollen doch bitte schon gefiltert werden dürfen.
Ja, also der Versuch, also zu sagen, okay, was in den USA jetzt gerade hochkommt, zu sagen, die Internet-Service-Provider sollen sich zum Büttel machen lassen und der Contentmafia zu diensten sein, wenn es darum geht, Robbkopien oder wie auch immer sie es nennen gerade zu unterdrücken. Man sieht ja wohin das führt, bei YouTube zum Beispiel, wo dann halt schon, oder Vimeo war es gerade.
Na, YouTube ist ja schon furchtbar genug. Dieses Video ist in ihrem Land nicht verfügbar.
Genau, aber dann war jetzt gerade diese Geschichte, dass den Leuten, die diese schönen Videos zur Voraussetzungsansprechung so gemacht haben, dass deren Videos von Vimeo gelöscht wurden, weil die GEMA...
Maja Sixtus war das und Alexander Lehmann.
Genau, dass deren Videos gelöscht wurden mit der Begründung, dass irgendeinen Büttel von einer GEMA, den die losgeschickt haben, der den...
Nee, das war nicht die GEMA, sondern es war der... Wer war denn das nochmal? Es war eine Third-Party-Firma, die beauftragt worden ist und deren Geschäftsmodell genau ist.
Aber wer hat sie denn beauftragt?
Das finde ich jetzt auch gar nicht verdrängt.
Ich glaube, es war die GEMA und es ging um die GEMA-Vermutung. Aber gucken wir gleich nochmal nach. Aber jedenfalls diese Firma, die den schönen Namen OBSEC trägt, also operational Security, steht?
Deren Geschäftsmodell ist quasi, im Internet in BitTorrent sich überall einzuloggen, in die ganzen Transfere und die IPs alle abzumachen, die da drin stehen, wenn sie glauben, dass der Torrent illegal ist. Oder die suchen eben auch auf YouTube und Vimeo nach Sachen, von denen sie glauben, dass da andere Leute das Copyright dran haben.
Die Entwicklung ist ja gerade...
Die GVU war das.
Die GVU, stimmt.
Das ist nämlich der Vollstreckungsarm der Contentmafia.
Der Contentmafia. Die Vermutung, die sie da noch haben, ist, dass mittlerweile der größte Teil des unbezahlten Transferierens von Content über diese Portale passiert, also YouTube, Vimeo und wie sie alle heißen. Und deswegen sind die da halt auch unterwegs, um halt dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Sachen da gesperrt werden und schießen da offenbar gerne an das Ziel hinaus. Aber das zeigt mir wieder ganz klar, wie halt ihnen doch politischer Inhalt unter dem Vorwand der Copyright-Durchsetzung da zensiert wird und offensichtlich von den Portalen, das auch nicht mehr geleistet werden kann, überhaupt zu prüfen. Dass diese Vermutung auch noch ansatzweise berechtigt sein könnte.
Also das geht ja auch noch ein Stück weiter. Wenn die Contentmafia jetzt sagt, wir möchten gerne Netzneutralität soweit aushöhlen, dass Raubkopien nicht mehr transportiert werden sollen mit der gleichen priorität, dann was die Hardware im Moment überhaupt nur leisten kann, wäre, dass man Beton benachteiligt. Also nicht, dass man Raubkopien benachteiligt, sondern dass man die Protokolle benachteiligt, von denen die die Contentmafia annimmt, dass die eben größtenteils zum Transport von Raubkopien benutzt werden.
Was eben ein klarer Verschluss gehen würde, als eine Zentralität wäre, weil zum Beispiel auch so Sachen, wie dieser Podcast hoffentlich der einst über Torrens transportiert wurde.
Ja, wollte wir machen. Wenn unsere Infrastruktur zu langsam wird, machen wir auch Torrens.
Aber bisher reicht es noch, glaube ich.
Bisher reicht es noch.
Ja, und der nächste Schritt ist dann natürlich diese Free-Strikes-Nummer in Frankreich.
Genau. Das ist auch schon seit einer Weile am Laufen. Wir haben das jetzt sozusagen hier als Übergang. Da gibt es jetzt keine neuen Erkenntnisse. Aber wo wir übergehen wollten, war... Also Free-Strikes ist ja auch bei uns, das kommt nur aus Frankreich, die Sache ist auch bei uns, am diskutiert werden. Und auch die Britten sind relativ weit, übrigens, in der Umsetzung davon, ob sie da nicht ein Gesetz daraus machen wollen.
Dann überlege ich sich mal, was passiert, wenn Free-Strikes mit ähnlicher sorgfalt durchgeführt wird, wie jetzt irgendwie diese Sparung auf Vimeo, oder?
Genau, das waren vier Siegstagsvideos. Das wäre schon einer mehr als benötigt, ne?
Gut, also ich denke mal, wenn, wenn irgendjemand hier Free-Strikes tatsächlich versucht durchzusetzen, dann werden wir auch wieder nach Karlsruhe ziehen.
Ja, natürlich.
Das dürfte doch mit relativ hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit verfassungswidrig sein, aber hoffen wir mal, dass wir es nicht so weit kommen lassen müssen. Ja, wobei es Free-Strikes waren. Du hattest da so eine schöne Geschichte ausgebuddelt mit dem Chef von Frankreich.
Genau, also hat mir jemand zugemalt, die Geschichte. Und also es geht folgendermaßen, der Sarkozy kommt ja aus der Ungarn. Und der Name Sarkozy ist wohl ein sehr häufiger Name bei Roma und Sinti. Das war also die Theorie quasi, dass er, also anders geschrieben, subtil anders geschrieben, nämlich mit einem Ö, aber quasi die Theorie ist, dass der Sarkozy ein Roma ist. Und das ist halt besonders interessant, weil Frankreich gerade dem Vorbild von Italien folgt und in großem Stil, auch andere Länder in Europa übrigens, in großem Stil Roma-Auszuweisung versucht. Und das ist eigentlich eine ganz furchtbare Sache. Ich weiß nicht, ist Deutschland eigentlich auch beteiligt? Also ich meine, wir haben ja auch unter den Nazis, die sind hier und Roma verfolgt. Insofern wäre das schon sehr anerüchig, wenn sie uns jetzt beteiligen.
Ich weiß jetzt nichts davon. Ich weiß halt nur, dass die natürlich aufgrund ihrer Lebensweise doch nirgendwo so gerne gesehen sind, auch in Deutschland. Und dass die Versuche, die es da immer wieder gibt, halt in den Gemeinden, die zu vergraulen, dann doch recht nachdrücklich sind.
Ja, aber das ist ja schon nochmal was anderes, als die offiziellen Auszuweisen.
Na klar, ja. Also die meisten, die in Deutschland unterwegs sind, haben ja mittlerweile auch, glaube ich, eine Staatsbürgerschaft aus einem der EU-Länder, also Rumänien oder Ungarn meistens. Aber klar, ich meine, das ist halt sicherlich ein Problem, mit dem man sich auseinandersetzen muss, weil die nun halt in ihrer Art und Weise zu leben halt möglicherweise inkompatibel mit dem allgemeinen Ansehen einer bayerischen Dorfgemeinde sind oder so. Aber es ist halt trotzdem irgendwie die aus der EU.
Na ja, sind die Fakka auch, ne?
Genau, ich meine, das kann ja wohl kein Stil sein. Ja, interessant ist, diese Geschichte, man erinnert sich ja so noch vor zwei Jahren oder so, gab es ja irgendwie einen großen Umfang von Flüchtlingsgeschichten, also die auf den Kanaren ankamen, die in Italien ankamen, die in Spanien ankamen, die in Marokko über die Zäune gestiegen sind und so weiter und so fort. Und vielleicht ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass diese ganzen Berichte mittlerweile echt zurückgegangen sind und liegt halt wohl nicht nur daran, dass weniger berichtet wird, sondern daran, dass da tatsächlich auch viel weniger passiert.
Wie, dass weniger ankommt oder dass weniger verfolgt wird?
Dass weniger ankommt, weil was die da machen, ist im Wesentlichen dieselbe, was die DDR an der Mauer gemacht hat. Da war ja so, dass die Mauer, na ja, haben wir zu, die Mauer war ja nur sozusagen die letzte Linie, die die Leute daran gehindert hat, in den Westen abzuhauen. Da war ein gestaffeltes System von Überwachung, das schon in den Dörfern weit vor der Grenze anfing, dass die Leute Bescheid gesagt haben, wenn da irgendjemand mal vorbeikam, den sie nicht kannten, dass die Leute an den bahnstationen angewiesen waren, zu sagen, wenn da Leute irgendwie ankamen, die irgendwie Wanderkarten hatten, die zu genau waren und nach irgendwo hinfragten, wo es verdächtig war. Es war dann so, dass die Wegmarkierungen falsch waren und so weiter, dass die Landkarten auch falsch waren. Und ähnliche Sachen macht die EU auch mit dem Kranz von Ländern um die EU. Die bezahlen die halt dafür, diese Flüchtlinge zurückzuhalten. Das heißt also dafür zu sorgen, dass die gar nicht erst bis an die EU aus den Grenzen kommen. Und die, die es dann doch versuchen, übers Wasser zu schaffen, die werden dann von einer eu-organisation namens Frontex, da hat man auch noch mal einen Link ins Verzeichnis, der sich dann verfolgt, ist meistens halt Küstenwache-Style, also mit Schiffen, die dann diese Flüchtlingsboote aufbringen und zurückschicken. Und es gibt da jetzt so ein Netz von Abkommen mit diesen so genannten sicheren Drittstaaten, wo die dann einfach hin, bevor sie in die EU überhaupt reinkommen, weggeschoben werden.
Also das ist in der Serie wieder die Geschichte in jeder Hinsicht. Denn es gibt da Dokumentarfilme drüber und man kann sehen, dass die halt nur direkt vor der Grenze Spaniens dann versuchen, die aufzufangen und nicht vor der Grenze Marokkos.
Also die, die das dann schaffen.
Die Idee ist, wenn die vorher absaufen, dann haben wir keinen Bürokratieaufwand hier. Also das ist schon sehr unmenschlich, die ganze Sache, die da abläuft. Und in Spanien ist das inzwischen ein signifikanter Wirtschaftsteil, die die Abwehr von Flüchtlingen. Beziehungsweise auf der anderen Seite natürlich, wenn die reinkommen, werden sie Schwarzarbeiter. Und das ist quasi das Interesse des Staates daran, die abzuweisen. Und die kriegen auch richtig EU-Gelder dafür. Also das ist ein signifikanter Teil von ihrem Bruttoinlandsprodukt.
Also die, woraus halt deutlich hinweist, ist, dass wir irgendwie als EU eine sinnvolle Einwanderungspolitik brauchen. So wie halt die Amis sind halt auch dran, die halt einfach ihre Einwanderung steuern, zumindest irgendwie, was nicht die Mexikaner angeht.
Lotterie. Green Card Lotterie. Also die Amis sind auch unmenschlich. Ich war mal in Südkalifornien unterwegs, und da gibt es eine Autobahn von LA nach San Jesus, also Richtung Mexiko im Grunde. Und da gibt es noch andere Großstädte auf kalifornischem Gebiet, und da geht die Autobahn halt hin, und da gibt es halt Rechtsküste, und da ist dann mal die Marine-Basis, und da ist mal ein Atomkraftwerk, und links ist halt Wüste. Also wenn du aus dem Norden Richtung Süden nach Mexiko fährst, links ist halt Wüste, und neben der Autobahn ist ein großer Zaun. Und ich habe mich halt gefragt, was soll das da, und habe dann mal die Eingeborenen gefragt, und die meinten, ja, da fahren wir noch nicht ganz Mexikaner.
Okay.
Also die haben da halt Wüste und haben auch absichtlich Wüste da, und haben da einen dicken Zaun, damit du denen nicht helfen kannst, wenn du die da verhungern siehst.
Und die stimmt etwa sogar per Gesetz in Arizona, glaube ich, verboten, dass du Wasser in der Wüste deponierst, wenn da Leute langkommen und so. Also so völlig...
Ja, also meine gute Einwendungspolitik hat einfach niemand.
Kanada, glaube ich, die haben keine Probleme.
Na die haben auch. Da sind gerade die Konservativen an die Macht gekommen, unter anderem mit dem üblichen Schleckgespenst. Echt?
Sie trafen neulich einen kanadischen Einwanderungs-Propagandisten von der Botschaft, der...
Die sind weniger nervig als wir und die haben diese Stunde. Die haben ja auch Platz unendlich.
Ja, und der sagte da so eine Liste von was sie suchen und wie schwierig es ist, mit welchem Beruf und welcher Lebenserfahrung einzureisen. Das ist ja bei uns auch so.
Die Propaganda glößt bei uns auch von wegen, ja ja, wir möchten gern die Inder haben, die sich mit der Tierhaut zählen.
Da war aber schon so, dass es den Antragsbogen aus dem Antragsbogen war. Wir waren ja gerade noch bei Frankreich eigentlich. Die Sache mit den Internet-Eingriffen, weil eine Sache, die dabei natürlich eine Rolle spielt, ist, dass man sowas natürlich benutzen kann, um solche Geschichten zu unterbinden, also das Reporting über solche Sachen zu unterbinden. Und es ist ja immer wieder so, dass unsere regierenden Klicken doch ein gewisses Interesse daran haben, bestimmte Geschichten untergehen zu lassen.
Also in zweierlei Hinsicht, auf der einen Seite, wenn man das Internet sehen kann, kann man Presse unterdrücken. Auf der anderen Seite ist das ein toller Versteckungsvorhang. Wenn man zu so einem Hallali bläst gegen die fiesen Einwanderer, da ist die Bevölkerung abgelenkt, da kann man im Hintergrund alles Mögliche machen. So ist das ja auch bei uns. Die Alternative der Klassiker ist, einen Krieg zu starten. Das haben wir ja auch im Afghanistan am Laufen. Das ist schon üblich, dass man innenpolitisch ein Feindbild konstruiert, um von den anderen Sachen abzulegen.
Interessant ist immer, dass diese Gerüchte, die es da so gibt, darüber, wie diese Eliten denn eigentlich funktionieren, was es da so an Geheimgesellschaften oder Geheimseilschaften und dergleichen Dingen mehr gibt. Da kam gerade diese hübsche Geschichte über, die zum Ende der Kaiserzeit, oder nicht zum Ende der Kaiserzeit, zur Kaiserzeit, gab es da so eine kleine Orgie im Grunewald. Anhand derer, Ja, richtig, genau, das war super. Anhand derer, denn da doch irgendwie auf einem Jagdschloss im Grunewald war es, glaube ich, nicht?
Also die interessante Sache daran war, dass das eben hauptsächlich die Adeligen waren, also die höheren Schichten der Gesellschaft, die sich da getroffen haben. Und die URL werden wir hier in unserer Linkliste machen. Aber das war ganz witzig, weil man da ganz gut sehen konnte, wie sich die Moralvorstellungen geändert haben.
Also die Geschichte war, die da haben sich halt zu einer Silvesterparty, glaube ich, oder Weihnachtsparty war es, halt so die höheren Schichten und Kreise getroffen.
Und was man heute eine Swingerparty nennen würde.
Und haben da halt, was man heute eine Swingerparty nennen würde, veranstaltet und sich dabei getreulich amüsiert. Und dummerweise gab es dann hinterher Fotos, die dann halt damals noch nicht auf Facebook landeten, sondern benutzt wurden, um die Leute zu erpressen. Und dann gab es Geschichten darum, wer nun der Erpresser sei.
Heute hat man Unfälle bei solchen Fällen. Früher hat man einfach ein Duell gemacht.
Genau, dann ging es darum, sich zu dualieren, was zu dem Zeitpunkt schon illegal war.
Aber der Kaiser hat es geduldet und zwar persönlich.
Also die Geschichte war wirklich herzallerliebst. Und die führt uns ein bisschen dahin, wie funktionieren denn eigentlich so die Bindungen in den Eliten. Und da hatte ich neulich ein sehr interessantes Buch in der Hand. Und zwar heißt es, Codes of the Underworld, How Criminals Communicate von Diego Gambetta. Diego Gambetta ist einer der, kann man sagen, wichtigsten Mafiasozialogen. Also der guckt sich heute die soziologie der Mafia an. Und der hat dieses Buch geschrieben, über die kriminelle Kommunizierung. Daran gab es, also neben extrem vielen anderen interessanten Beispielen, gibt es da eine Geschichte, nämlich darüber, dass schon Kinder anfangen, bis hin zu Politikern. Über geteilte Geheimnisse, also über gemeinsames Wissen, über moralisch, ethisch, kriminell verwerfliche Dinge ein Bündnis zu bauen. Also wenn ich weiß, dass wir beide wissen, dass wir gemeinsam irgendeinen Unsinn gemacht haben, wenn wir darüber beide den Mund halten, ist halt so die...
Das bindet uns beide.
Das bindet uns beide. Und er hat dann da einen sehr faszinierenden Absatz darüber, dass ähnliche Mechanismen natürlich auch in der Politik oder in Eliten stattfinden. Also zum Beispiel halt die politischen und gesellschaftlichen Eliten in England, sozusagen vom Mitte des 19. bis mit dem Ausgehen des 20. Jahrhunderts, beruhten halt zum großen Teil darauf, dass die halt homosexuell waren, was zu diesem Zeitpunkt halt in England gar nicht ging. Aber da gab es halt große Verbrüderungen, also gut, da gibt es diese Gesellschaften, die voreinander wussten, dass sie halt homosexuell sind und das halt sehr in Verborgenheit getrieben haben und darüber halt ihren Bund geschmiedet haben. Nachdem dann halt Homosexualität auch in England halt nun kein großes Problem mehr ist, und du halt irgendwie auch problemlos halt im Zeitpunkt wahrscheinlich ein schwuler Premierminister sein kannst in England, fällt natürlich diese Möglichkeit der Bündnisbildung weg. Und die Frage stellt sich dann natürlich, was machen die denn dann jetzt so?
Ob man zu härteren Sachen greift?
Und eine der Theorien ist halt, die durch diese Belgien-Geschichte mit Dutron, diesen Verbrecher, der da Kinder entführt und vergewaltigt hat, hochkam, dass offensichtlich da es einige Politiker-Kreise zu geben scheint, die sich jetzt ja eben an Kindern vergehen oder im Besitz von Kinderpornografie eben als gemeinsamen Bund benutzen, also als gemeinsames dreckiges Geheimnis, um einander erpressbar zu halten und damit bei der Stange zu halten.
Das erinnert mich auch ein bisschen an den Sachsen-Sumpf, der war so ein CDU-Ding, was da lief, und da hieß es auch, dass die gemeinsam, was war das Menschenhandel und Positivität?
Nee, da gab es auch tatsächlich Kinder, aber es gab auch Kinder und es war auch dieses. Diese Sachsen-Sumpf-Geschichte ist ein sehr klassisches Beispiel dafür. Also das lief halt ganz genauso offensichtlich. Und da, also dieses Buch nochmal zur Empfehlung, wir tun es auch in die Links, kurz auf die andere Welt, extrem lesenswert. Er erklärt zum Beispiel auch, warum in den Beförderungskomitees an Unis meistens die mittelmäßigen Professoren so stark vertreten sind. Der Trick ist folgende. Wenn du ein guter Professor bist, der halt akademisch was drauf hat, also wissenschaftliche Leistungen bringt, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du im nächsten Cycle, wo neue Stellen vergeben werden, noch da bist, gering. Dementsprechend könntest du dich nicht an Deals halten.
Ich dachte, das hat Zeitgründe.
Nein, ich befördere deinen Guy, dafür befördere ich zum nächsten Mal meinen. Aber wenn du so gut bist und am nächsten Mal nicht mehr da bist, dann wird sich der Nachfolger nicht mehr an den Deal erinnern, nicht mehr daran halten können. Dementsprechend sind es Leute, die beim nächsten Mal garantiert noch da sind, davon bevorzugt.
Es gab auch gerade eine Studie, die mich ein bisschen daran erinnert. Und zwar ging es darum, dass die, also in Gruppendynamik allgemein, dass die Leute, die freundlich und altruistisch agieren und anderen Leuten die Arbeit machen, dass die am unbeliebtesten sind. Weil nämlich die anderen Leute dann ein schlechtes Gewissen haben, dass sie das nicht tun. Und weil das quasi die Ansprüche erhöht, versucht man die dann rauszueckeln. Also das ist schon...
Wie gesagt, also kurz auf die andere Welt. Must Read war so eines der Bücher, die ich am augenöffnendsten fand in den letzten Jahren. Du hattest diese Heimgesellschaft noch fast, nämlich diese Bilderberger-Reschichte.
Genau, die Bilderberger. Also die Bilderberger ist so ein Grundstock der Verschwörungstheorien seit vielen, vielen Jahren. Denn das ist so ein Treffen seit, ich glaube, 54 oder so treffen die sich. Und das sind immer Staats- und Regierungschefs, die sich aber quasi privat auf einem Schloss oder in einem Hotel treffen und dann da ein Meeting machen. Und die auch immer versuchen, die nächste generation einzuladen. Und ich habe die ja, ich weiß halt nicht, weil die nie irgendwelche Presseerklärungen ausgegeben haben.
Wurdest du eingeladen?
Nein, nein, aber ich habe eigentlich aufgehört, die ernst zu nehmen, als die vor ein paar Jahren Guido Westerwelle eingeladen haben. Die haben ja, was ist das denn für eine groteske Fehlanschätzung? Und heute, heute ist ja mal unser Vizekanzler. Also da ist vielleicht doch was dran. Man weiß es nicht. Also warum ich die jetzt erwähnen wollte, hier bei den Geheimgesellschaften, ist, weil die nämlich, die sind unter ihrer eigenen Bekanntheit quasi zugrunde gegangen. Also sie treffen sich immer noch, aber die sind halt nicht mehr geheim. Weil es ist so ein wichtiger Teil aller Verschwörungstheorien sind diese Bilderberger und auch die trilaterale kommission. Und da gibt es einige solche Sachen. Aber die Bilderberger sind halt so der Blitzableiter quasi, wo jeder mal drüber berichtet. Und insbesondere hat auch die Mainstream-Presse angefangen, darüber zu berichten. Und einen besonders hartnäckigen Reporter hat der Guardian hingeschickt. Der Mann heißt Charlie Skelton und der hat die regelrecht gestalkt. Und es ist so weit gegangen, dass der Auftragsehend von der Polizei da um den Sicherheitskräften verhaftet wurde. Der war wirklich anstrengend. Und deswegen hat die Bilderberger-Gruppe dieses Jahr angefangen, eine eigene Website zu machen. Und das ist ganz witzig, weil ich die halt finden wollte. Und gehe dann halt zu Google und frage, Bilderberg? Und das ist irgendwie, ich glaube, 12 oder so. Weil davor sind alles andere Verschwörungszeiten, die sich mit den Bilderbergern beschaffen.
Und die dann die entsprechenden Domains haben. Und die sind richtig.
Und die sind so spät gekommen, die Bilderberg. Also bilderberg.org zum Beispiel gehört zu einem Verschwörungsfuzziliener. Also wirklich auch übelste New-World-Order, wie Propaganda, die wollen uns alle töten, verbreitet. Und die sind praktisch so populär unter den Verschwörungstheoretikern, dass ihre tatsächliche Domain überhaupt nicht zu finden ist in den ganzen Verschwörungsgraben. Das ist ganz witzig.
Ja, bei diesen Kinder-Porno-Geschichten, gab es ja gerade diese Meldung, dass angeblich das Löschen nicht gut funktionierte.
Das ist auch ein Sumpf. Das Hauptproblem ist, dass es halt so viele Interessen gibt, bei diesem ganzen Kinder-Porno-Löschen. Die eine Hälfte möchte das gerne funktionieren sehen und die andere Hälfte möchte es nicht funktionieren sehen. Und die Leute, die es halt funktionieren sehen möchten, sind Eko, das ist der Verband der Internet-Provider. Und die haben angeblich eine Studie gemacht, hieß es in einem Pressbericht, ob das Kinder-Porno-Löschen denn funktioniert. Und dazu gibt es eben eine internationale Hotline namens InHope. Und die haben in Deutschland, wenn ich glaube ich über Jugendschutzpunkte jetzt vertreten oder so. Jedenfalls, die soll man anrufen, wenn es um Länder geht, in denen es eine lokale Niederlassung von InHope gibt. Und dazu gehört inzwischen zum Beispiel so was wie Russland und natürlich die USA. Und die allermeisten Kinderpornos werden in den USA gehorstet, einfach weil da Free Speech sehr hoch gehalten wird. Und weil die andere Vorstellungen davon haben, dass als Kinderpornos illegal seien, als wir. Also bei denen ist es zum Beispiel so, dass eine Manga-Darstellung nicht unter Kinderpornografie fällt. Und bei uns wäre das anscheinend Chronographie oder so. Also das heißt einfach selbst, wenn bei uns was klar gegen die Gesetze verstößt, heißt es eben nicht, dass es in den USA auch gegen die Gesetze verstößt. Und dann kriegt man die halt auch nicht gelöscht. So und jetzt gab es halt diesen Pressebericht und der hat gesagt, Eko habe über Inhoop versucht Sachen zu löschen und das sei irgendwie Monate später immer noch alles im Netz gewesen. Das war irgendwie die Zusammenfassung.
Das war die Zusammenfassung, genau. Aber das sagte nicht die Studie eigentlich, ne?
Aber die Studie selbst, habe ich das ganz anders gesagt. Da ging es nämlich darum, dass sie absichtlich Länder genommen haben, die nicht über Inhoop sind, weil nämlich Inhoop die Statistiken gar nicht erhebt, welche Seiten jetzt eigentlich aus dem Netz verschwinden. Das heißt, sie haben absichtlich nur solche Seiten betrachtet, die eben nicht Inhoop-Ländern sind. Und da war die Quote eben besser, weil da sind sie selber zu den Providern gelaufen. Während bei Inhoop gab es eben noch Probleme, dass sie dann das gar nicht an den Provider gemeldet haben, sondern an die lokale Polizei. Und dann landet es halt beim FBI auf dem Tisch und vergammelt da.
Genau wie bei uns bei der Polizei.
Genau wie bei uns bei der Polizei. Also das heißt, das Problem bei dieser Meldung und überhaupt bei den ganzen Sachen ist, man weiß halt immer nicht, wie man da jetzt vertrauen kann und wem nicht.
Ja, zumindest die Experimente, die halt so im Umkreis gemacht wurden, mit einfach beim Provider-Bescheid sagen, sind durchschlagend innerhalb von Stunden. Also insofern kann ich mir dann, also obwohl es gab noch diese lustige Theorie von Kertschall, die behaupteten, dass es Honeypots sind, die nicht gelöscht werden können.
Genau, das war die schönste Theorie, die es. Man kann in den USA keine Sachen gelöscht kriegen, weil das FBI die ja selber dahingestellt hätte, um quasi Kinder-Porno-Konsumenten zu finden. Das ist natürlich völlig abwiegig, dass die Tausende von Seiten dahingestellt haben als Honeypot.
Ich weiß nicht, wenn du überlegst, was sie bei Drogengeschichten gemacht haben, dann würde ich jetzt nichts für abwiegend halten. Und die Contentmafia wollte dann auch noch mit ins Boot. Die hatten noch gesagt, dass wenn man das mit dieser Netzneutralität sein lässt, dann könnte man noch ganz prima auch bei Kinderpornografie erledigen.
Also das ist überhaupt bei der Contentmafia seit einer Weile so, dass die Raubkopien und Kinderpornografie und Terrorismus immer in einem Atemzug nennen. Das ist bei denen dasselbe.
Genau, also Raubkopierer finanzieren Terrorismus mit Kinderpornografie oder so ähnlich.
Genau, und Drogen.
Und Drogen, ganz wichtig.
Und Raubkopien, weil der Normalbürger nicht versteht, wo eine Raubkopie jetzt eigentlich schädlich ist, versuchen sie auch umzubesetzen, damit es sowas meint wie gefälschte Medikamente. Und da kann man nämlich schon einsehen, dass es vielleicht nicht gut ist, wenn das Medikament irgendwie hinanlegt.
Wobei es ja gerade diese Geschichte gibt. Da gab es gerade diese Geschichte, dass auch in deutschen Apotheken Medikamente, die als gefälscht bezeichnet wurden, verkauft wurden. Interessant war dann aber, als man dann bei dieser Geschichte ein bisschen weiter nachgegraben hat. Und da stellte sich dann heraus, dass es nur nicht gefälschte Medikamente waren, sondern nur in Deutschland nicht zugelassene Zubereitungen. Das heißt, die haben sich irgendwo die Wirkstoffe besorgt und haben dann daraus so Apotheken, also Selbstmischungsmedikamente gemacht.
Ja, diese Schaumung noch hier.
Also man kann da, bei solchen Geschichten muss man immer ganz genau hingucken, und sich wirklich mit den Details beschäftigen.
Na und es gab noch die Sonneborn-Sache, oder? Hörst du dich? Sonneborn, der ex-Titanic-Chefredakteur, der hat für das ZDF, glaube ich, einen Pharmareferenten befragt und hat dem gegenüber so getan, als wäre das jetzt off the record, und der hat dann endlich da in den Kopf und Kragen geredet. Und unter anderem hat er erzählt, also der Pharmareferent hat unter anderem erzählt, ja ja, die gefälschten Medikamente aus China seien ja völlig ungefährlich, weil da sei ja das Gleiche drin. Das ist ja das Geschäftsmodell. Aber das sei halt für unsere Wirtschaft schädlich, das als Problem. Und es ist natürlich total gau für die Pharmaindustrie, wenn das manchmal so aussagt.
Also die spannende Frage ist dann halt, wie denn die Ökonomie von so einem Medikamentenfälscher funktioniert. Weil wenn der eigentlich eine Weile im Geschäft bleiben will und wenn man halt jetzt nicht nur Pillen presst, sondern tatsächlich da Pharma betreibt, dann macht es natürlich Sinn, die Wirkstoffe tatsächlich da reinzutun, die also zum Beispiel in Mische Pharmaunternehmen, die machen ja jede Menge Wirkstoffnachbauten, einfach deswegen, weil sie halt da diesen massen Patentfonds nicht haben. Also, die können ja die ganzen europäischen Wirkstoffe für den Binnenmarkt fertigen und machen sie auch in großem Umfang. Und diese natürlich irgendwie kosten nur Zehntelzents und nicht irgendwie Dutzende von Dollar. Naja.
Also Pharma, da müssen wir mal eine eigene Sendung machen. Das nächste Problem ist ja, dass die Medikamente alle ein Verfallsdatum haben, was nichts mit dem tatsächlichen Verfall der Medikamente zu tun hat.
Da können wir mal tatsächlich eine eigene Sendung machen. Mal gucken, ob ich jemanden so eingeladen bekomme. Ich kenne nämlich jemanden, der arbeitet in einer organisation, oder hat in einer organisation gearbeitet, die abgelaufene Medikamente nach Afrika schibt. Oh cool. Dann gucke ich mal, ob ich den rankriege und wir mit dem reden können. Ja, jedenfalls hat die Pharmamafia doch offenbar einiges zu verbergen, wie es scheint.
Eigentlich waren wir ja bei den Kinderpornos und nicht bei der Pharmamafia. Wie haben wir das denn nicht mehr geschafft?
Alles dasselbe.
Sind wir voll auf dem Zug der Contentmafia aufgestiegen. Und das ist all das selbe bei uns. Also es gab nämlich noch eine andere lustige Story jetzt gerade. Da ging es nämlich darum, Kinderpornos wird ja bei uns immer so als Totschlagargument benutzt. Das ist fast so gefährlich wie Mord und Totschlag. Aber in der Praxis ist es eben nicht so. Also erstens ist die Strafe für den Besitz von Kinderpornografie relativ klein. Das ist nämlich zwei Jahre Knast, wenn es so kommt. Oder halt Geldstrafe sogar nur.
Und da gab es jetzt noch diesen Fall, oder?
Und es gab gerade einen Fall, wo bei Beamten Kinderpornos gefunden wurden. Das eine war, glaube ich, ein Lehrer, was ich ja besonders hart finde, weil der ja mit Kindern zu tun hat. Und es gab auch einen Polizisten, was ja auch schon ziemlich krass ist. Und die haben beide ihren Beamtenstatus nicht verloren. Also es gab Disziplinarverfahren gegen die, aber die sind in Berufung gegangen und haben Recht bekommen und dürfen weiter Beamte bleiben. Und da kann man mal sehen, wie viel unser Apparat intern eigentlich, wie gefährlich die Kinder Pornografie finden.
Das hat offensichtlich zum großen Teil einfach nur ein Vehikel, ne?
Na klar.
Gut, wie kommen wir denn jetzt zur Streetview?
Wir hatten, naja, wir waren gerade bei Sachen, die man zu verbergen hat.
Das ist kein toller Übergang, aber ich mein, ja.
Das klang besser, als wir ihn aufgeschrieben haben.
Also bei Leuten, die was zu verbergen haben, weil gerade offensichtlich scheinen ja auch große Teile Deutschland was zu verbergen zu haben. Es ging ja diese Woche sehr, und zumindest letzte Woche davor auch sehr heiß, um Streetview. Und was ich so ein bisschen bemerkenswert an dieser Debatte finde, ist, dass die sich ausschließlich darum kümmert, was jetzt Streetview sein soll. Also halt Bilder, die heute im Zweifel ein, zwei Jahre alt sind.
Und auch keiner Leitstellungsmerkmal. Es gibt andere Anbieter, die sowas auch nicht.
Eben kein Leitstellungsmerkmal, aber interessant finde ich halt, dass eben die diskussion darüber nicht weitergeht. Also dass es halt keine Erweiterung dahingeht, darüber mal zu diskutieren, was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn diese Streetview-Kameras nur noch 300 Euro kosten und man die einfach auf jedes Taxi montieren kann und die über 4G-Netzwerke, die wir in drei bis fünf Jahren haben werden, ihre Daten live uploaden. Hattest du dieses Video gesehen von Microsoft Research, wo sie in Bing Maps mal da richtig die...
Da konnte man live so eine Videos einblenden und das war schon richtig geil.
Also live geogetagte Videos in das Microsoft-Equivalent von Streetview einblenden und halt auch live aggregiert Bilder von Leuten, die bei... Peekasa heißt das bei Microsoft, nee.
Peekasa heißt das Google...
Wie heißt das Microsoft-Equivalent? Na gut, also in dem Fall so ein Online-Bilderservice, wenn du da geogetagte Fotos reintust, dann kann diese...
Die haben glaube ich Flicker genommen, weil die mir ein paar Assistenten hatten. Also jedenfalls die Technologie existiert dafür.
Also Microsoft hat da diese Technologie, um aus geogetagten Bildern, die erst C-Dragon, die Technologie, die in die Szene einzusortieren. Das heißt also, die so zu drehen und zu schieben, dass sie vom Bildpunkt des Betrachters aus eine Ergänzung des Bildes bieten. Das heißt also, wenn du halt auf einem Platz stehst und auf diesem Platz gibt es irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 50 oder 80 geogetagte Bilder, dann finden die die Kanten und die Häuser und können die da halt einsortieren.
Und es gibt sogar die rekonstruktion, das ist richtig abgefahrene Technologie.
Und damit kann man dann halt so eine Art Streetview mit geogetagten Bildern bauen. Also einfach nur mit den Bildern, die halt die Leute sowieso hochladen. Und die interessante Frage, die sich da stellt und über die man halt diskutieren muss, ist, ab wann ist denn eine neue Qualität? Also ab wann muss man da möglicherweise die Rechte von Firmen und die Rechte von Individuen trennen? Und was haben wir denn eigentlich davon, dass das jetzt passiert? Also bei Streetview wird das jetzt reduziert auf dieses, die Leute haben ja nur Schiss, dass man über die Hecke guckt und irgendwie keine Ahnung, man kann halt sehen, ob sie in einer billigeren Gegend oder einer teureren Gegend wohnen. Das kann ich auch schon im Luftbild sehen. Also das sagt, da braucht kein Streetview dazu. Mit den sonstigen Geomarketing-Datentests, also die neue Qualität von studio ist nicht da, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall eine neue Qualität an Aufregung, die aber leider nicht dazu führt, dass die Leute mal ein bisschen weiterdenken und darüber nachdenken, was soll denn eigentlich möglicherweise anders sein? Also wo sind denn die Grenzen zwischen nützlich und möglicherweise dann schon unangenehm?
Wobei ich ja glaube, dass das ein Sturm- und Wasserglas ist. Die Aufregung kommt nicht von den Leuten, sondern kommt von ein paar Medien wie den Sommerloch und von ein paar Politikern wie dem Westerwelle, die halt gerade im Abstimmungstief sind und gedacht haben, sie haben ein populäres Thema gefunden.
Na mal gucken, wie das weitergeht mit dem Streetview-Besetz.
Naja, wir haben beim Brainstorm über die Sendung überlegt, was wäre denn, wenn die alle mit Geigerzählern rumfahren würden?
Genau, 3D-Scanner haben sie schon drauf, also Laser-3D-Scanner. Und wenn man halt schon mal alle Straßen abfährt, könnte man auch eigentlich einen Geigerzähler reintun. Im Moment sind die einzigen, die mit dem Geigerzähler rumfahren, offensichtlich die Jungs vom Roten Kreuz. Ich habe da mal ein bisschen hinterher recherchiert, die bekommen tatsächlich von der Feuerwehr und vom Bundesamt für Strahlenschutz. Messfahrzeuge kommen aus dem Roten Kreuz, sozusagen, bestellt.
Völlig bizarr, wieso das denn?
Wegen der Dirty Bomb Panik, weil jetzt ist das entstanden.
Warum macht der denn das Roten Kreuz, ist doch nicht das Bundesamt für Strahlenschutz.
Damit wir die Flächendächen kriegen, der Roten Kreuz hat eine Menge Freiwillige und das Bundesamt hat halt nur einen Zwang.
Ach, das ist eine Geldfrage heute auch.
Naja, ich meine, das Problem ist halt, was passiert, wenn jetzt halt, nehmen wir mal das szenario Dirty Bomb. Wir glauben jetzt mal, wir halten mal kurz den Tom Clancy-Mode an und haben halt irgendwie mal eine fette Dirty Bomb, die halt irgendwie in Franz-Werberg explodiert ist.
Stargarderstraße.
Dann muss halt jemand da hinfahren und mal das Ausmaß der Versäuchung messen. Und dafür brauchst du halt eine Menge Messwaben und dafür brauchst du eine Menge Leute, die bedienen, die du sonst nie brauchst. Also du tust die nützlich freilegen, die du ohnehin hast, bei Roten Kreuz und bildest die an den Messfahrzeugen aus. Macht schon Sinn unter diesem Tom clancy-szenario. Was nun passiert ist, ist, dass offensichtlich da ein solcher Messfahrzeug von Roten Kreuz auf einer Trainingsfahrt unterwegs war und es machte mit einer Stagel der Straßenprenzler Black Schmack und der Geiger-Zehler sprang an und dann ging da eine lustige kleine Sommerposse los. Also sie haben dann gefunden, dass da in einem Stückchen Asphalt ein offensichtlich schon relativ alte Strahlenquelle rumlagt, die, wie sich den jetzt auf Nachfrage herausstellte, nicht wie ursprünglich angenommen dazu diente, die Dichtigkeit von Rohren, also von Schweißnähtnissen, messen, sondern zur Füllstandsprüfung in großen Tanks dient.
Da ist überhaupt kein großer Tank, oder?
Nee, muss offenbar verloren gegangen sein, keine Ahnung.
Aber die ist wohl genau in so einer Ritze zwischen zwei Betonplatten im Asphalt, oder?
Also ich hab schon mir einen Blog fotografiert, also die lag offensichtlich genau auf seiner Ritze zwischen zwei Hardasphaltplatten in dem weichen Asphalt. Also muss offenbar da reingefahren worden sein. Und was ich halt auch bisher nicht wusste, bevor ich es dann halt nachgelesen habe, dass halt solche radioaktiven Elemente, also radioaktiven Kapseln benutzt werden, um in großen Tanks mit zum Beispiel Erdöl oder sonstigen Sachen, wo man halt nicht direkt drin messen kann, sondern den Füllstand zu messen.
Wieso kann man da nicht direkt drin messen?
Na ja, weil so ein Erdöl ist halt eine extrem zähe Angelegenheit. So eine sehr, sehr fiese Pampe.
Wie funktioniert das denn? Verstrahlst du es? Und wenn beim Rauskommen, dann mehr Strahlen?
Also es gibt halt zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder baust du auf dem Boden von dem Tank eine Strahlenquelle und misst oben die Dämpfung. Also wie viel durch die darüber liegende Pampe.
Doktor fragt mich da ein bisschen, ob das Operat 13 ist.
Naja, der Punkt ist halt, das verstrahltet ja nicht. Also das führt ja nicht dazu, dass das hinterher radioaktiv ist, weil da keine radioaktiven Partikel reinkommen und die Strahlung nicht so stark ist, dass da eine Isotopenumwandlung stattfindet.
Naja, das kommt ja in der Verstrahlung aus.
Das ist halt natürlich schon eine Gamma-Strahlung, aber die ist halt wiederum nicht so stark, dass da halt ein großermaßen Isotopenumwandlung stattfindet. Das ist halt die eine Methode und die andere Methode ist halt, du machst halt an einer Seite von Tank auf bestimmten Höhen mehrere von diesen Quellen und auf der anderen Seite mehrere Detektoren und misst dann darüber halt, wie die Abschattung durch die Flüssigkeit ist. Naja, sowas jedenfalls war es offenbar.
Na, wobei, man benutzt ja auch Strahlung in der Medizin.
Ja, das war so einer der lustigeren Kommentare bei mir im Blog, wo dann auch mal einer vorbeigefahren ist und Geigerzähler. Ich habe auch noch mal mehrere Leute in meinem Blog, die meinen Blog lesen, die Geigerzähler haben.
Nein, du auch auch, oder?
Ja, ich habe auch noch einen.
Mach dich mal nicht so laut lustig.
Ich mach mich ja nicht lustig, ich freu mich darüber. Stell dir mal vor, wir hätten wirklich eine Dirty Bomb. Wir könnten meine Blogleser nun überlegen. Und der merkte dann noch an, dass sich die Strahlenintensität von dieser Strahlenquelle da in der Straße in einer geringeren Größenordnung bewegt als die, die man abbekommt, wenn man neben jemand in der Straßenbahn steht, der gerade eine Schildgrößenuntersuchung mit einer relativeren Marke hatte. So viel zu den kleinen Risiken des Alltags. Und wenn man natürlich keine gute Gelegenheit für eine bevölkerungsverunsicherung vorbeigehen darf, haben offenbar ein paar Scharfsbeude. Das lasse ich gerade heute und tagsüber und ich schließe schon auf ihn zwei Wochen näher. Da in der Gegend um die Stageler Straße gefakte Behörden schreiben, verteilt, wo sie die Anwohner zum Strahlentest eingeladen haben.
Na in die Briefkästen?
In die Briefkästen, ja. Also da... Super!
Es gibt keinen Grund zu beunruhigen, da kommen sie mal zu uns am Strahlentest.
Also es war auch sehr großartig, als diese aktion da war, der Stageler Straße, da hatten sie die komplett abgeriegelt, den ganzen Block da. Also Fußgänger konnten noch durch. Aber die Polizei hat dafür gesorgt, dass man da halt nicht mit dem Auto durchfahren kann. Dann haben die natürlich vorne gefragt. Dann haben die Polizisten gesagt, ja, also da wurde erhöhte radioaktivität festgestellt. Kunstpause? Während dem Leuten das Gesicht im Glitz. Ist aber nicht gefährlich, außer sie setzen sich da direkt drauf. Sehr schön. Also man kann offensichtlich auch als Schutzpolizisten ein bisschen Spaß haben. Ja, Atomkram, das ist ja immer wieder faszinierend.
Da sind wir auch immer wieder gerne dabei, das als Themen hier zu verwenden. Wir haben noch zwei, also wir haben ja letzte Sendung eine Menge über U-Boote gemacht. Und eine Sache, die mir in der Zwischenzeit aufgefallen ist beim Wikipedia-klicken, war, dass es da ein sehr interessantes technisches Problem ist, wie man eigentlich mit U-Booten kommuniziert. Also normalerweise im Zweiten Weltkrieg waren die halt noch hauptsächlich aufgetaucht und nur zum Angriff sind die untergetaucht. Aber moderne Atom-U-Boote sind schon mal so was wie ein Monat oder zwei untergetaucht. Und je nachdem, wie weit die untergetaucht sind, desto schwieriger ist es eben da funkpenetration zu kriegen. Das heißt, die normalen UKW-Sender oder auch nur AM, die kommen halt nicht so weit. Die kommen nur bis 20 Meter ins Wasser.
Na selbst für die 20 Meter brauchst du schon monstros große Zeug. Also das sind halt schon Low-Frequency-Antennen. Also Low-Frequency-Funk und der geht dann halt so 10, 20 Meter ins Wasser rein, je nach Salz-Anteil des Wassers. Das ist der Salz-Anteil des Wassers, das bestimmt, wie tief du mit LF da reinkommst. Und um dann mit den U-Booten tatsächlich, die U-Booten zu erreichen, reden kannst, auf dem Wege nicht mit ihm, wird dann E-LF verwendet, also Extremely Low-Frequency. Und da reden wir halt dann so von so 80 Hertz, ungefähr so was wie 76 und 82 Hertz waren so die.
Nimm mal die Russen an, 76.
Ne, 82, die haben ich dann 76, ja.
Und das ist halt brutal faszinierend, wie solche Sender funktionieren. Denn wenn man da also eine reguläre Antenne bauen würde, sagt Wikipedia, dann bräuchte man eine Antenne der Größe 3000 Kilometer. Und das ist ja doch ein bisschen unrealistisch, selbst für ein großes Land.
Unhandlich, ja.
Und was man deswegen tut, ist, dass man eine bestimmte Stelle sich aussucht, um diesen Sender auch zu bauen, wo nämlich der Boden wenig leitet. Und das ist eigentlich das Gegenteil dessen, was man bei Sender normalerweise sucht. Also man sucht sich eine Stelle, wo der Boden schön isoliert, und dann macht man im Abstand von irgendwie 60 Kilometer groß, haut man zwei fette Elektroden in den Boden und macht in die Mitte so eine station mit Kabel, die ist in der Mitte, damit das Signal bei beiden Elektroden gleichzeitig ankommt. Und dann, weil der Boden schlecht leitet, wird eben die Erde als Antenne mitbenutzt. Und da braucht man derartig viel Energie. Ich habe jetzt keine konkreten Zahlen gefunden. Aber das ist halt richtig doll viel. So viel, dass man da eigentlich ein Kraftwerk danebenbaut, normalerweise, wenn man so etwas betreibt. Und deswegen, weil das eben so aufwendig ist, haben auch nur die Russen und die Amis so etwas gehabt. Die Briten haben wohl eine Weile darüber nachgedacht, das in den schottischen Bergen zu bauen, aber das haben sie dann verworfen, weil es zu teuer ist.
Faszinierend ist dann, dass dadurch, dass bei Sendern, es ist ja immer so, dass je höher die Frequenz ist, desto mehr Bandbreit hat man da. Und je niedriger die Frequenz ist, desto weniger Bandbreit hat man da. So bei so diesem ELF-Zeug.
So 300 Bord, ne?
Weniger. Also es ist halt so, dass es tatsächlich so, mit irgendwie allem Drum und Dran kommt man da so in den Bereich von paar Dutzend Worten die Minute. Und es ist halt dann so, wie man das so aus den Filmen kennt, dass es so ganz langsamer Teletext wird. Sehr langtickert so.
Und es ist halt One Way. Also es ist völlig undenkbar, dass ein U-Boot die Elektronik oder eine Antenne dabei hat, um dann beantworten zu können. Deswegen weiß man also nicht, ob das U-Boot überhaupt noch existiert, wenn man das schickt. Weil man überhaupt keine Antwort kriegt. Die müssen dann auftauchen und mit dem Satelliten antworten.
Meistens ist es so, dass sie dann halt eine Boje hochschicken. Und da gibt es halt zwei Wänden. Die eine ist halt eine Boje, die über ein Kabel angebunden ist. Das heißt also, die wird dann ausgerollt an einem langen Kabel.
Und wenn die funksenden, ist das ja wieder audible, das ist alles.
Und sendet dann halt. Und die andere ist halt, sind halt One Way-Boeien. Das heißt also, die Boje wird ausgesetzt, bleibt unter Wasser, also unter der Wasseroberfläche mit einem Timer. Dann fährt das U-Boot Volldampf voraus von der Stelle weg. Und nach der Zeit taucht die Boje auf und setzt die Nachricht ab, die das U-Boot nach Hause schicken wollte. So ist dann halt so.
Damit du ja trotzdem weggibst, dass du in der Gegend warst.
Damit du dann so grob weggibst, dass du in der Gegend warst, machst du halt auch nicht auf. Die haben, glaube ich, nicht so viele von diesen Bojen an Bord.
Ah, das ist schon heftig.
Und dann versenkt sich die Boje halt, wenn sie gesendet hat. Und da gab es ja dann noch diese Ultra-Low-Frequency, die dann bei so was wie 2,2 Hertz waren. Und die sind dann tatsächlich auch an beliebigen Stellen unter Wasser empfangbar, also richtig tief auch so. Und da ist aber das Problem, dass dementsprechend die Übertragungsbandbreite sich nur noch im Bereich von einzelnen Bits pro Minute bewegt.
Also schon bei diesem ELV ist es so, dass die Russen ihren Sender in Betrieb genommen haben, hat ein Hobby-Funker in Norwegen gemerkt. Einfach weil der bei sich die Ausschläge gesehen hat. Das ist schon auch, den Sender sieht man halt. Der macht richtig, der ist dann immer um die Welt empfangbar.
Ja, schon interessant, was sie so getrieben haben im Krieg. Dabei hat noch nicht mal alles die Klassifereiter erfahren.
Ja, also inzwischen ist die Idee, diese Sachen zu benutzen, um nach einem Atomschlag der Gegenseite noch kommunizieren zu können. Dann ist ihnen aufgefallen, dass der gegen diese stationen wegnügen könnte. Deswegen ist der aktuelle Plan, dass man so eine Flotte von Flugzeugen hat, die man hochschickt und die auf allen Frequenzen senden und empfangen können. Das sind so ein paar Spezial-Boings. Das ist das Relay dann. Die Idee ist ja auch, dass ein Atomschlag einen großen Einfluss in die Ionosphäre hat und Sachen kaputt machen kann. Deswegen ist nicht klar, ob in solchen Fällen noch Satelliten funktionieren würden. Das ist schon brutal. Die haben also eine Flotte von Flugzeugen, die sie dann tonusmäßig hochschicken. Die Hoffnung ist natürlich, dass die Atombomben auf der Erde explodieren und dass man dann mit seinem Flugzeug relativ sicher ist. Wenn man nicht direkt darüber ist, dann könnte ich...
Oder der Gegner weiß, dass es genau um diese Flugzeuge geht.
Ja, aber was sie da für einen Aufwand getrieben haben, da werden noch einige schöne Sachen kommen.
Diese Überhaare, Horizontradars könnten wir gelegentlich auch noch mal kramen. Vielleicht nächstes Mal. Wo wir gerade bei Radar sind, da gab es ja diesen schönen Move, den die Russen gemacht haben. Und zwar haben die in Süd-Ossetien und Abchasien den Wegbruchkolonien innerhalb von Georgien, die nur von Russland anerkannt sind, haben sie mal so ein S300, was so eines der fortgeschrittenen Luftabwehrsysteme ist, stationiert. Es handelt sich dabei um so ein Gerät, also es ist eine Gruppe von Fahrzeugen, die stellt man dahin und dann hat man so ein paar hundert Kilometer Reichweite, wo man verhindern kann, dass da Flugzeuge oder Marschleukörper durchkommen. Und wenn man sich dann mal so die Geografie anguckt, da lohnt es sich, so eine Landkarte auszupacken, wo denn genau dieses komische Süd-Ost-Jetz-Hiland, Abchasien, so ist, dann stellt man fest, dass es dann so ein sehr schmaler, eine schmale Landbrücke ist Richtung Iran. Also ausgehend von der Theorie, dass möglicherweise die Israelis den Iran angreifen wollen, ist halt eine der möglichen Anflugrouten, halt genau übers Schwarze Meer und dann über den Luftraum von Abchasien und Georgien. Und da die Israelis sowohl in Georgien intensiv unterwegs sind, als auch in Bulgarien und Rumänien, wo sie halt Trainingsexercises mit Hubschraubern machen und solche Sachen.
Und denen auch gut Hardware verkauft haben.
Und da gerade so ein Hubschrauber runtergefallen ist, deswegen, das wird ja auch noch aufgefragt, war sozusagen die Annahme, dass möglicherweise halt ein Teil des Luftschlags darüber gehen könnte, durchaus berechtigt. Die Türkei hat ja gesagt, dass sie auf keinen Fall halt das Duiden wird, dass die Israelis ihren Luftraum benutzen.
Syrien wohl auch eher nicht.
Na gut, Syrien hat halt ein Problem, dass sie sich möglicherweise nicht so ganz wehren können.
Aber Syrien wird es wohl zumindest merken, wenn die Israelis da vorbeifliegen. Und dann wäre Iran gewarnt.
Und dann würden sie den Iran Bescheid sagen können. Und insofern ist halt, dass die Russen jetzt da genau da ihren hochmodernen Luftabwehrsystem hinstellen. Es wird so wie ein Schachzug, dass die Dame einmal hinter der Bauernreihe vorrückt. Und klar machen, hier geht nicht so viel lang.
Und dann bleibt Israel nur eine Route, und die wäre über Saudi-Arabien.
Oder über den Irak halt.
Oder über den Irak. Aber da ist also relativ klar die Ansage der Amerikaner, dass sie das verhindern würden. Wenn der unilateral los schlägt, ohne vorher einmal, ohne Erlaubnis zu fragen.
Na ja, die Amis sind natürlich da in einer echt beschissenen position. Also wenn die Israelis halt sagen, sie würden jetzt unilateral los schlagen und sich nicht von den Amis davon daran hindern lassen.
Das glaubt den Amis natürlich keine Sau.
Glaubt den Amis das sowieso keiner. Das heißt, die Amis müssten dann in dem Fall wahrscheinlich mitmachen. Weil die Israelis alleine versuchen lassen, was sie wahrscheinlich nicht schaffen würden, den Iran daran zu hindern, weiter nuklear aufzurüsten oder überhaupt ein Nuklearprogramm zu entwickeln, mit dem man Bomben bauen kann. Dann würden sie sich vermutlich gezwungen sehen. Hinterher wären wahrscheinlich die Beziehungen zu Israel komplett um einmal. Deswegen ist Israel sich vermutlich noch momentan nicht so richtig viel versprechen.
Also der Lacher ist ja, es gab die Theorie, Israel könnte über Saudi-Arabien fliegen. Das ist die letzte Alternative, die in Frage kommt. Und Saudi-Arabien ist eigentlich die konkurrierende Islam-Variante zum Iran. Das heißt, eigentlich mögen die sich nicht, kämpfen auch beide um die Hegemonie in der Gegend. Das wäre also tatsächlich denkbar, dass Saudi-Arabien weghubt, wenn Israel über ihr Gebiet fliegt. Allerdings, wo kann das eigentlich her? Irgendeiner hat irgendwie gemeint, das sei schon quasi verhandelt. Das hätte ich schon passiert.
Das war eine Sunday Times-Meldung hier.
Genau. Und plötzlich, also Saudi-Arabien war da natürlich in einer Scheißlage, weil das können die unmöglich zugeben in der Öffentlichkeit. Die mussten sie also schnellstmöglich, größtmöglich davon distanzieren und mussten demonstrativ da ihre Luftabwehr nochmal testen und hochfahren. Und die Route ist jetzt also auch zu. Das heißt...
Moment, aber da gab es dann auf Debka das Gerücht, dass dieses Manöver nur dazu diente, sicherzustellen, dass im entscheidenden Augenblick ihre Luftabwehr aus ist auf dem vor allem warten Korridor.
Debka sollten wir dazu sagen, das ist so eine Zeit, als Israel...
Ja, das ist so eine israelische Rumour-Outlet, die halt offensichtlich von den israelischen Diensten benutzt wird. Also was die sagen, ist halt...
Das ist eine hochspannende situation, sag ich.
Vorsicht genießen. Also der Hintergrund von dem ganzen Spiel ist natürlich so, dass die... also wer da noch mitspielt, sind natürlich die Russen und die Iraner und die Amis. Und die Amis, wenn sie den Iran zu sehr unter Druck setzen, haben sie halt das Problem, dass der Iran ihnen im Irak genügend Ärger machen kann, dass das mit dem Abzug dann mal so gar nichts wird oder halt hinterher definitiv kein pro-amerikanisches Regime mehr in der Nacht ist. Ähnliches gilt zum Teil auch für Afghanistan. Die Russen haben jetzt natürlich mit den Iranern ein Prima-Druckmittel, die Amis weiter da in der Gegend irgendwie gebunden zu halten, also dafür zu sorgen, dass sie halt irgendwie da nicht genug Truppen haben, um ihnen in ihrem nahen Ausland, wie sie so schön sagen, Ärger zu machen. Also zum Beispiel Georgien und die ganzen anderen Republiken da.
Überhaupt die russische Diplomatie in der Gegend wird größtenteils so, also sie designt die Amis dann möglichst lange hinzuhalten.
Ja, das ist präzise genau ihre Aufgabe. Also diese Geschichte, dass sie jetzt den Iranern halt irgendwie den Kram für Bushehr gegeben haben, also für einen Atomreaktor, dass sie den anfangen können, ist halt genau Teil dieses ganzen Spiels, sodass sie halt dafür sorgen, dass die Iraner den Amis genügend lange Ärger machen, dass sie halt aus dem Irak nicht so richtig weg können, ist halt durchaus irgendwie für die Russen genau das richtige Spiel. Also die profitieren für diese ganze situation ganz erheblich. Die Amis würden sich eigentlich am liebsten gerne mit den Iranern auf irgendeinen Deal einigen, dass sie halt aus dem Irak rauskommen. Aber dadurch, dass die Iraner nun natürlich sagen, wir basteln hier, oder müssen sie sagen, wir basteln an Atomwaffen.
Klaum, mach doch mal die Embargos weg, sagt der Iran dann.
Naja, vor allen Dingen sind die Atomwaffen natürlich für den Iran halt ein prima Faustpfand, um sich bessere verhandlungspositionen zu erwirtschaften. Dass das funktioniert, hat man ja nun schon bei Nordkorea gesehen. Und insofern sind die Amis da halt gerade in einer echt nicht beneidenswerten situation.
Na und, diese ganze Embargosache floppt halt vor sich hin. Die wir da am lautesten lieber dachten ist China natürlich, denn der Iran sitzt auf den drittgrößten Ölreserven der Welt und exportiert die immer schön, wer sie halt haben will. Und seit die Amis dann Embargo verhängt haben, hat halt China kaum noch Konkurrenz und kann also so viel einkaufen, wie sie wollen. Und die haben vorher echt Probleme gehabt, ihren Ölbedarf zu denken. Insofern, China ist der lachende Dritte und der lachende Vierte sind eben die Russen, weil die können eben da im Grunde alle ihre ganzen Hightech-Deals immer mit dem Iran machen. Das haben sie ja auch getan. Haben den ja auch Luftabwehr verkauft und haben sogar angekündigt...
Die haben die aber noch nicht geliefert.
Doch, doch, sie haben einen Teil davon. Tor haben sie geliefert.
Aber noch nicht die S3-Bahn hat es ja.
Die wollten dann auch, genau. Das heißt, die Russen spielen ein ganz witziges Spiel an der Stelle, weil sie haben immer den Amis gegenüber so tun, als würden sie ihre Embargos einhalten und dann aber tatsächlich doch im Grunde alles liefern, was sie da zu liefern ist.
Diejenigen, die da gerade nicht so gut aussehen, sind echt die Amis am Ende.
Also die Amis sind aber zumindest bemüht, an der situation was zu ändern und haben jetzt also versucht, sich aus dem Irak zurückzuziehen. Das war doch mal nur so ein Propagandabzug, ne? Die US-Presse hat den auch voll empfänglich ignoriert. Das war mir witzig.
Ich hab's gar nicht so verfolgt.
Da ist halt überhaupt niemand darüber berichtet, außer halt BBC. Und so in den üblichen Foten ja. Und in den üblichen, also nicht mal Fox News. Wie? Weil die halt immer mal nicht leiden können. Ach so. Nicht mal die haben irgendwie berichtet. Also das ist auch kein vollständiger Rückzug, sondern es ist halt ein Rückzug der Kampftruppen. Und da hab ich so ein ganz witziges Zitat gefunden in der Army Times. Das ist die Propaganda-Zeitung der US Army. Und die haben halt geschrieben, die Second Striker Brigade Combat Team von der 25. infanteriedivision, die ist jetzt immer noch im Irak deploit. Und zwar als Mitglieder der Advice and Assist Brigade.
Also Freunde und Helfer, ja.
Ja, das sind jetzt die Freunde und Helfer. Vorher die Strike Force und jetzt eben die Assist and Advice Brigade. Und das ist aber bei den Eingeborenen noch nicht so eingekommen, dass es jetzt zwar Soldaten sind, aber dass es eigentlich Freunde und Helfer sind. Und die fliegen halt nach wie vor bei irgendwelchen Bomben und die anschlägen und fliegen die Soldaten um die Ohren. Also war das ein Propagandaschachzug gewesen, der nicht so wirklich funktioniert hat.
Die einzige Chance, die Armys da wirklich hätten, wäre halt, wenn sie da irgendwie so was ähnliches wie ein stabiles...
Mit kleinen Strahlensätzen.
Nee, das würde nicht funktionieren, weil sie diese Trennung zwischen den Sonnischen und den Shiiten nicht in den Griff bekommen. Und nachdem sie halt die alte Balance da zwischen Sonnischen und Shiiten halt zerstört haben...
Ja, das ist echt verkackt. Also das ist auch nicht zu reparieren.
Also ihr versucht da sowas wie Demokratie einzuführen, das ist natürlich von vornherein etwas fragwürdig. Insofern, in dem Stil, wie sie es sich vorgestellt haben, war doch offensichtlich sehr blauäugig. Blauäugig und Demokratie, da war auch noch was.
Ja, also wir sind ja mit den Hauptthemen durch und haben gesagt, wir können vielleicht am Ende noch ein bisschen Zeit nutzen, um noch mal über Liquid Democracy zu reden.
Genau, weil wir gerade von Demokratie waren, Liquid Democracy. Für die, die es noch nicht bekommen haben, Liquid Democracy ist so der Partei hinter einer Versuch der Piratenpartei, was mal anders zu machen als die bisherigen Parteien. Also die Parteien bisher zeichnen sich immer dadurch aus, dass sie sowas wie...
fraktionszwang haben.
Naja, fraktionszwang ist davon noch nicht mal betroffen, sondern da geht es ja nur um die innerparteiliche Demokratie. Also früher im Staatsverkundunterricht in der DDR haben wir gelernt, dass die DDR auf einem System beruht, was sich demokratischer Zentralismus nennt. Und der funktioniert folgendermassen. Der demokratische Zentralismus funktioniert so, dass es also eine Struktur gibt, die halt von einer Zentrale regiert und von unten hoch aus den Parteigliederungen werden Vorschläge und Verbesserungen nach oben gereicht. Und dann werden die dann begutachtet und umgesetzt und die Spitze wird demokratisch gewählt. Und wenn das jetzt irgendwie bekannt vorkommt, genauso funktionieren halt angeblicher die Parteien heutzutage auch. Also es gibt halt irgendwie die Parteiführung und die fraktion und die...
Den gutmütigen Diktator.
Naja, der wird dann demokratisch gewählt. Insofern ist es demokratischer Zentralismus. Im Osten auch glaube ich. Nun wissen wir ja alle, wie gut es funktioniert. Deswegen haben die Piraten sich gesagt, wir machen es mal anders und haben halt versucht, dieses Liquid-Democracy-System einzuführen. Und da gab es dann halt diesen kleinen Hick-Up, dass einige Leute da festgestellt haben, so naja, Liquid-Democracy bedeutet, dass Vorschläge innerhalb eines Web-Systems eingestellt werden, zum Beispiel für neue Programmpunkte in Parteiprogrammen oder wenn die dann mal irgendwann zum Beispiel in einer koalition beteiligen für verschiedene Dinge, die halt in der koalition entschieden werden sollen und dass die Parteibase direkt über jeden dieser Vorschläge abstimmen kann. Und dafür gibt es dann noch so ein cleveres System, die sogenannte delegation, dass man sagen kann, okay, dieses Thema interessiert mich nicht. Ich habe irgendwie an Fischereirechten sowas von kein Interesse. Da delegiere ich meine Stimme für dieses Thema an jemand, der davon Ahnung hat. Und wenn der auch keine Ahnung davon hat, dann kann das wiederum auch an jemand delegiert. Also da entsteht sozusagen so eine Transparentmachung von so Seilschaften, sowas bisher bei den Parteien im Verborgenen ablief. Also dass halt diese Hinterzimmerdeals liefen, so okay, wenn ihr irgendwie bei irgendwie Einwanderungspolitik mit uns stimmt, dann stimmen wir bei euch mit Frauenpolitik und so. Wird damit halt transparent gemacht.
Also transparent auch nur, wenn es auf der Webseite steht, und das ist genau der Knopfpunkt gerade gewesen.
Genau, also es ist so, dass die, der Fröschland war ja bisher halt, wie zu sagen, die Accounts sind halt komplex und nü, und wer dann halt sich um ein Amt berührt innerhalb der Partei, da könnte es dann halt schon mal so die soziale konvention geben, dass der dann sich dann deanonymisiert. Also dass man sehen kann, an wen delegiert er, von wem hat er delegation bekommen, wie hat er sich dann so bei Abstimmung verhalten. Und das hat nun einige Leute innerhalb dieser Partei nicht so richtig gefallen. Und da gab es dann halt den großen Aufschrei, aber der Datenschutz. Und nun haben sie halt, die haben die Piraten offensichtlich einen Kompromiss gefunden. Die Details sind noch nicht so genau angekundigt, wollte ich die Tage nochmal tun, wenn ich habe. Aber jedenfalls ist dieses Liquid-Democracy-System jetzt tatsächlich live geschaltet seit einer Woche, glaube ich. Liquid-Feedback heißt die Software. Und wird da auch sehr intensiv genutzt. Und das lohnt tatsächlich mal der genauen Betrachtung. Also wenn ihr jemanden kennt, der irgendwie bei den Piraten mitmacht und dazu mal zum System hat, dann bittet ihr ihn nochmal oder sie, das euch mal zu zeigen und euch das zu erklären. Weil das hat tatsächlich die Chance, wenn das funktioniert, die gesamte Parteienlandschaft komplett umzukrempeln, weil dann eben nicht mehr zum Beispiel im Antragskomitee des Parteitags gefiltert werden kann, dass bestimmte Anträge nicht durchgehen oder verwässert werden oder mit anderen Anträgen zusammengelegt werden, mit denen sie nichts zu tun haben und dass diese ganze Kompromisslere, Kompromisslerei und Hin- und Her-Schieberei von Stimmen zum Beispiel auf Landesverbands-Ebene oder diese ganze Proporzdenken, dass irgendwie ein Vorschlag nicht angenommen werden kann, nur weil er von Landesverband Exypselon kommt, weil das alles dann halt wegfallen kann. Insofern sind wir da sehr gespannt, was daraus wird. Also es ist eines der spannendsten Experimente der hübrigen deutschen Parteiengeschichte und da können wir den Piraten eigentlich nur viel Glück wünschen, dass es irgendwie zum funktionieren gebracht werden kann.
Einen der Hauptpunkte haben wir noch nicht erwähnt bei Liquid Democracy, nämlich die delegation kann jederzeit zurückgenommen werden. Im Moment ist ja so, man wartet bis zur nächsten legislaturperiode und hat dann Wege an andere Leute rein, wegen irgendwelcher Versprechungen und hat überhaupt keine Handhabe gegen die, wenn die sich nicht an die Versprechen halten. Und bei Liquid Democracy entzieht sich dann einfach die delegation.
Und zwar kann man das sogar noch vor der Abstimmung tun, also vor der finalen Abstimmung, wenn man sieht, dass sich der bei den diskussionsbeiträgen und Änderungsanträgen zu dem Antrag nicht entsprechend meinen Vorstellungen bewegt, dann kann ich ihm die delegation immer noch gleich entziehen. Also eben deswegen dynamisch und liquid. Ich bin da sehr gespannt drauf. Also ich hoffe mal, dass es irgendwie so gut funktioniert, wie es halt bei den ersten Tests hier so in den Berliner Landesverband funktioniert hat. Sehr spannend. Also ja, ein Thema, wo es auch so ein bisschen um Transparent ging, wo wir gerade bei Liquid Democracy waren, ist ja auch im Kontext der demonstration am 11. September die Kennzeichnungspflicht von Polizisten, die im Rahmen der letzten demonstrationen nach der kleinen Prügelorgie da doch sehr stark ins Gespräch kam. Und da fiel so ein Artikel auf von wann war der?
Und der war, ich glaube, Tagesspiegel. Und da ging es eben auch darum, ja, das versprechen die uns ja schon seit so vielen Jahren. Und wenn man mal nachzählt, dann versprechen die uns das seit 60 Jahren. Und lustigerweise, direkt nach dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs gab es in Berlin sogar eine Beschriftung der Polizisten.
Ach, echt?
Ja. Und das hat gehalten bis 48 oder so, steht alles in dem Artikel, den wir an die Linken lesen zu tun. Okay. Also jedenfalls, wenn man mal hinguckt, wird man feststellen, wir wären seit 60 Jahren hingehalten mit fadenscheinigsten Argumenten.
Gut. Dann sind wir durch. Vielen Dank. Das war Alternativlos, die Folge 3. Wie immer gibt es neben der Sendung einen kleinen Flatterbutton. Neuer Monat, neues Flatterglück. Wenn ihr draufklickt, wird es auch das audio besser irgendwann, hoffen wir mal.
Ihr könnt auch auf die Alten nochmal draufklicken.
Ihr könnt auch auf die Alten nochmal draufklicken, wenn ihr möchtet. Dann können wir uns noch ein Eis zu dem audio gönnen. Und vor allen Dingen können wir auch für die Bandbreite ein bisschen bezahlen, was auch nicht so schlecht ist. Dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.